et c'est l'heure à présent d'un fonds
apte ox
la chasse aux fausses informations c'est
avec anthony st léger bonjourbonjour
raphaël bonjour à tous alors que les
occidentaux s'inquiètent de mouvements
militaires russes à proximité de
l'ukraine et de la crimée des images
satellites de ces manoeuvres sont
partagés sur les réseaux sociaux anthony
hayes effectivement à l'instar de ce
tweet au qui nous dit maintenant
vladimir poutine poutine est en train de
se moquer nous qui reprend dans son
tweet ce qui s'apparente vous le voyez à
un tweet du journal américain de new
york post avec pour légende de nouvelles
images satellite montrent l'ampleur du
déploiement russes l'ont long de la
frontière avec le cren photos satellites
à la pluie la même idée chez cet
utilisateur de facebook qui nous dit lui
qu'un message clair est envoyé au
président byden alors que voit-on
précisément sur cette image et bien on
va vous mais regardez vous lisez trois
mots let's go brandon et des tanks
aligner si on prend un peu de recul qui
forment ces trois molettes comprend
donne vas-y aller brandon quel rapport
avec joe biden viens on va revenir un
petit peu en arrière on est le 2 octobre
2021 le 2 octobre dernier aux états unis
lorsque lors d'une course automobile
dans l'alabama le vainqueur brandon
brown est interviewée par une
journaliste de la chaîne sportive nbc
dans la foule des conservateurs
farouchement opposé à joe biden utilise
ensuite le président en utilisant le mot
anglais qui commence par f est assez
vulgaire pas besoin de vous faire un
dessin mais apte à l'antenne et bien la
journaliste le remplace par des
encouragements aller brandon en clair
joe biden devient let's go brandon cela
a été perçu comme une censure des médias
libéraux effectivement c'est l'une des
conséquences et puis la deuxième
conséquence raphaël tout à fait c'est
que ce slogan let's go brandon à devenu
ensuite un cri de ralliement finalement
de certains conservateurs on le voit ici
utilisée même dans des produits est
dérivé donc un cri de ralliement pour
certains conservateurs et partisan
donald trump regarder ce membre
républicain de la chambre des
représentants qui s'en est même amusé en
arborant ici un masque avec le slogan
est question en question n'est quelques
semaines seulement après la course
automobile on revient à nos tanks
l'image satellite qui montent donc cette
inscription let's go brandon est bel et
bien une un fox a effectivement le
compte twitter regardez c'est celui ci
ce compte qui a publié donc le tweet que
je vous ai montré et il se continuer sa
série satirique et c'est même écrit ici
il se spécialise dans la fabrication de
même et dans le fait de poster des
choses pas forcément très sérieuse la
capture d'écran elle a été faussement
attribuée au new york post mais elle a
été prise pour argent comptant par de
nombreux internautes et si vous tapez on
va le faire ensemble regardez le titre
réel lui de du new york post dans
twitter bien vous tombez sur un tweet du
new york post du 20 janvier mais
regardez la led comme brandon a disparu
vous trouvez bien cette encre us à la
frontière a aligné mais sans le mot en
question et cette image satellite elle
vient d'où et vient elle vient d'ici de
ce2 elle a été prise en fait par la
société américaine maksar technology
après l'annonce récente des manoeuvres
militaires évidemment et on la retrouve
ici dans ce reportage de nos confrères
du de reuters ont né le 20 janvier un
peu de pédagogie anthony montrez-nous
donc comment on recherche une image avec
son smartphone c'est assez simple très
rapide je vous en parle souvent pour ce
qui est de l'ordinateur mais sur le
smartphone c'est faisable évidemment on
télécharge d'abord une application de
recherche d'image inversée évidemment
elles diffèrent selon le système
d'exploitation va découvrir ensemble
petit à démonstration va prendre à
l'exemple ce soir d'une vidéo dont on
vous parlait hier ici mienne entonne
fnaut cette vidéo partagée affirmant que
plus d'un million de vaccins avaient été
détruits au nigeria avec plusieurs
publications félicitant au passage le
peuple nigérian pour à sa révolte contre
la vaccination leur ont fait une capture
d'écran vous voyez une fois que celle ci
est réalisée vous vous rendez sur l'une
des applications en question vous
chargez à la photo vous pouvez même vous
le voyez choisir le moteur de recherche
de votre choix et puis vous allez vous
allez le voir tomber sur différents
résultats et en l'occurrence pour ce qui
est la photo d'hier vous tombez
notamment sur une vidéo de décembre 2021
un reportage de nos confrères d'euronews
où l'on apprend comme vous l'expliqué
antoine hier que cette destruction a
bien eu lieu mais que ça n'a rien à voir
avec une révolte contre la vaccination
les vaccins étaient périmés donc tout
simplement inutilisable merci anthony st
léger c'était parfois à toc